now let's talk about something different
about
future technologies also in this field
the science engagement plays a very
important role
um i'm eager to talk about this with
martin kugler he is with the austrian
institute
of technology hello great to have you
with us martin
your institute is applying science to
build
the green infrastructure of the future
what is your vision about it
yes the ait austria institute of
technology is austria's largest research
and technology organization
we have around 1400 researchers and
experts
who support business and society
particularly in the areas of
digitization
decarbonization and other challenges of
climate change
to answer your question on the one hand
we have a strong expertise in fields
like
energy mobility systems low emission
transport health and buyer resources
digital safety and security automation
and so on
on the other hand this specific
expertise is not enough because we have
to have a few in the whole systems
this is very important because it's not
possible to solve our complex
problems with a single solution
so to cope for example with climate
change
it is necessary to combine expertise
from different disciplines
we have to use synergies between them
and we have to avoid
unintended consequences of our actions
that's our main point how we deal with
these problems
okay well the expert talks you are
hosting during the summit today
gives an image on how technology can
shape a green future
can you give us a little a pre-taste a
little schmunkel as you say in austria
into some of the most interesting
insights
yes of course in our expert talk we get
some insight in the fields natural
resources
urban planning battery research
cooperative digital technologies and
mobility systems
and for me the most interesting issue is
the future design of citizen regions
at the ait we installed recently a
so-called
city intelligence lab where we combine
new digital methods for designing smart
cities
in this lab it is possible to modify
any design and compute immediately
the effects
this has for example on mobility of the
people on energy demand
or on heat episodes in the summer and so
on
this is possible by removing all
barriers
between different fields of expertise
such as architecture energy mobility and
so
instead of this former sectoral view
we use cutting-edge technologies such as
artificial intelligence
augmented reality to integrate all
aspects in one platform and this allows
an integrated urban planning together
with planners
with city administration with the people
who are living in the cities with
stakeholders and politicians
and this forms the basis for innovation
and solutions for future cities and
regions which are
most sustainable more resilient and more
livable okay looking forward to learn
more in your event thank you very much
martin coogler for giving
us an insight